hey guys Ryan right here I'm gonna be
checking out the trailer for Mad Max
fury road the legacy trailer don't know
how much more I can say about this movie
but let's check it out it's a good cable
company oh I get what they're here yeah
what Mel Gibson was respected
time
this wasted land but most Hall I
remember sir wash
the man we call max
tell me a story mention loosen family to
one not too many do you think you're the
only one that suffered on the best
chance you've got
hey he was so cool
Wow dude
Wow
that movie look so good looks so [ __ ]
good oh my goodness
remember when Mel Gibson was max holy
[ __ ] was he awesome
I still like Mel Gibson I have defended
Mel Gibson many times on this channel I
know he's [ __ ] up badly
trust me I get the gravity of it but
he's still really good at what he does
and he's apologized heavily so maybe we
can forgive him now everyone's looking
forward to the new Mad Max movie now
they put together this trailer showing
like road warrior Beyond Thunderdome Mad
Max and it's awesome to see then I think
it's a great reminder of just how
legendary Mel Gibson is to see them
transitioning into today it's like just
comparing the way it looks from the
original films to today it looks like
[ __ ] beautiful and dark and haunting
I love just how it looks just like the
original but even more and even neater I
love it it looks so fantastic and it's
from George Miller come on man he's the
only one who could pull off this [ __ ]
film if they're gonna reboot this
franchise I don't remember if Tom Hardy
is playing the same max or not I think
he's a different one but I would like it
if Mel Gibson can at least make a cameo
hopefully in the sequel of fury road
because the face that we're getting is
equal so I'm gonna be introducing a new
rating system here how it's gonna go is
go into the theaters wait for it on DVD
or not even bother with it all I gotta
say is Mad Max fury road I will
definitely be going to the theaters
anyway guys thanks for thank you so much
for talking that trailer was out I loved
being reminded of some of my favorite
actors out there and just how legendary
their work was if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the reel
rejects and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter where we
like attention